the second coming by william butler
yeats turning and turning in the
widening gyre the Falcon cannot hear the
falconer Things Fall Apart the center
cannot hold
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
the blood-dimmed tide is loosed and
everywhere the ceremony of innocence is
drowned the best lack all conviction
while the worst are full of passionate
intensity surely some revelation is at
hand surely the Second Coming is at hand
the second coming
hardly are those words out when a vast
image out of spiritus Mundi troubles my
sight somewhere in sands of the desert a
shape with Lion body and a head of a man
a gaze blank and pitiless as the Sun is
moving it's slow thighs while all about
just real shadows or the indignant
desert Birds the darkness drops again
but now I know the twenty centuries of
stony sleep were vexed to nightmare by a
rocking cradle and what rough beast its
hour come round at last slouches towards
Bethlehem to be born for an analysis of
the poem watch this video or check out
the next poem in this series